seven
densities the law of one
this in many ways is a phd in
metaphysics
the nature of reality the nature of
being the nature of consciousness
who we are and why we're here
i highly recommend checking it out the
law of one
the links in the bio below it's one of
the most profound
influences on my
being
one of the main aspects is the idea of
the one
infinite creator and how that one
infinite creator
is exploring through all of these
creation designs
of which this is just one
and i even made a little jingle to go
along with it
one infinite creator expressing itself
hey one infinite creator expressing
itself ura
one infinite creator expressing itself
ha and when you get to some of these
states of self-realization of the
non-duality of god of source of infinity
this child-like humor presence
bliss peace essence just channels
through
moment's moment
another main teaching of the law of one
is that everything is
love light
and everything is in service to that
exploration
and we'll see here there's no polarity
there's no
right or wrong there's no disharmony and
there's no lack
everything is just infinite perfection
these are more advanced states
of consciousness that are able to
transcend the idea of right and wrong
and polarity and disharmony and lack
and just be from a place of
infinite perfection on a
moment-to-moment basis
and naturally it's in service to
others in service to the absolute
highest
so there's only identity are you an
egotistic
individual greedy
narcissistic pathological megalomaniac
butterfly affecting negativity
constrained with all of the onion layers
of identity
or are you the one infinite creator are
you god
are you source do you recognize that the
other is actually another expression of
the self
because when you do all of those
egotistical
individualistic constraining focal
pointy
behaviors melt they melt they dissipate
they dissolve
they fade away
densities can be thought of as
evolutionary leaps
we're gonna have some visuals here in a
moment
like mastering belts in martial arts
and the third density is the human
density and that is highly sought after
and we'll unpack that here more in a
moment
so let's check out these graphics
this first one is actually the graphic
of one of the guests we've had on the
show
good friend umberto braga thanks so much
for making this
go and support him
so seven density model of consciousness
so as you can see here these
evolutionary leaps they look like
the different belts that you get in
martial arts
as you keep graduating going through the
school
and starting off in that first density
is very physical
energetic materials elements second
density being physical
plants animals third density being
physical humans
fourth density some variable physicality
fifth density pure energy six density
pure dens
pure energy unified thought forms and
then seventh density
pure energy all objective awareness
so
we're going to unpack each of these
densities in detail
and i would like us to sort of keep the
idea
of the visual of the evolutionary leaps
in this model in mind
because you didn't just randomly
get here right
we've graduated beyond nihilism and
we've graduated
beyond thinking this is all an
accident and that i'm just randomly here
we've graduated far far beyond that
and so now we're asking some of the more
profound metaphysical questions what is
infinity what is god what is source what
is
what are we doing here
and so the general idea of the time
scale according to raw
and again raw is the sixth density
social memory complex that was channeled
by carla ruckert and this is
around 1980 or so so about 40 years ago
and so that in itself should be
something interesting to people
in the sense of okay well how about
off world more advanced
intelligence that has
taken in more of
all that is and is trying to share that
with us
maybe we should be a little bit more
[ __ ] serious about
listening probably
probably
we need to be more humble and less
hubristic
and so this is that time scale according
to raw so this third density this human
density is
a massive choice point along the
trajectory
and the choice is either service to self
me more for me or
service to other
authentic genuine loving compassionate
true service
to the flourishing of all
because you recognize that that is you
this is all one being
all right so let's unpack these
first densities so
the the eighth density
and the first density are the same
it's very much like the snake eating
its tail this is very much like the
oroboros
very perennial spiritual
wisdom and symbol that's been used for
thousands of years
and this is beingness awareness so a new
universe is
born which incorporates all that the
creator has
experienced of itself
it requires a lot of imagination to
expand oneself as truly closely to
infinity as possible
because an infinite amount of
exploration that's occurring with
completely different creation designs
with completely different
vehicles of sentience
with completely different
words of experience that are being
written
on completely different blank pages
of awareness consciousness sentience
it requires a lot of imagination
to think about
what we had incorporated
and what we're exploring here and what
we're going to
explore as we hit that god head
and that's what this is and so we
launched off and here we are
in this creation design where we have
the reality as it appears to us if it's
very it's
illusory but it's the way that it
appears to us
as these fundamental building blocks of
earth wind fire
water a very timeless presence for
billions of years
no awareness of self yet and then in two
second density you have growth and
movement
the evolution of plants animals and
organic life the next level of exploring
this is where things like chimps begin
to rub
off on each other and that creates
the separate self that creates the other
and this is also where
humans the third density trains second
density
pets so if you have dogs or cats
you may not even know but you're
literally training them
to become ready to be humans
which is also what we did you can't just
come in and
incarnate into a human body
without having went through the
schooling the classes of what it even
requires to
actually harmonically
occupy this incredible
instrument and vehicle think about that
right it'd be like if i said that
we're gonna throw a three-year-old
into the phd classroom
no like obviously the three-year-old has
to go through
some classes some densities
before it can enter into the phd realm
of dancing
and play you have to level
up you have to gain these martial arts
belts
through the densities
and this is what's fascinating is then
you sort of get a better understanding
of
what the structure of our reality is
truly like and what to do
to maximize your own well-being and also
the well-being
of all and so let's move on to that
so now we're in our good old
third density self-awareness
and choice
this is very exciting this is where we
find ourselves at as humans
many of us are still in the extremely
limbic
primal behavioral systems
but many of us have moved up a little
bit beyond that and are
trying to figure out how to harmonize
through all of the war and despair that
we've had
and some of us are poking out of third
density into fourth density and even
fifth density and
very very few beyond that but then
they're acting like the teachers to the
vast majority in the third density to
try and get them to level up to pierce
the veil and self-realize
so this is the axis upon which creation
itself
turns this is what raw calls the
mind-body
spirit complex which is a really good
term for it
it's it synthesizes and summarizes the
actual vehicle itself
mind body spirit complex the vehicle
itself and the vehicle's relation to god
infinity source is really well
synthesized with those four words
in this third density so consciousness
is the ground of all experience
it's the center of the universe
it's the paper in the screen
so consciousness and awareness is the
blank
paper it's the blank screen
all of the modulations the thoughts
feelings emotions beliefs and
objects that are experienced
are all of the different social media
apps and all of the different
emails and phone calls and texts and
videos
that happen on the device but we are the
screen
before the modulation and if you
recognize
that screen is eternal that screen is
infinite that screen's
essential nature is bliss and peace that
is what is meant by enlightenment
and that's when you really melt into
that
self-realization that infinity
that god source within you
and then you recognize that same god
source infinity
in others and that's when you
can only be in service to them that's
when you can
only be from the absolute highest
morality
the most fascinating aspect to infinity
in my opinion
is the veil of forgetting
you can't write a better
play than this this is
the best game in town it's so
obvious it's right under our noses how
beautiful
this is and how it's by far the coolest
thing that could
possibly exist
literally god source infinity
has the capability to
veil ourselves we can
veil ourselves and forget
who we are that is so fascinating
on the macro metaphysical level that is
by far the coolest thing that i have
ever learned about who we truly are the
fact that we have that
feature that mechanism that ability is
so
damn awesome and that's why
we call it hide and seek that's [ __ ]
what this is it's hide and seek
and that's why kids love hide and seek
that's basically infinity as a child
before it gets polluted by the matrix
subscriptions that give it ego and
layers of identity
that is the actual nature of what
infinite god source is just playing hide
and seek
realize that you are hiding
and that there's actually something to
seek and that what you're seeking has an
extremely
not only pragmatic benefit to maximizing
your own health and well-being being in
bliss and peace
for yourself and for everyone around you
but also it is the most true thing about
you
is to remember who you are you have to
pierce the veil that's what the greeks
called
an amnesia which is the remembrance
hypnosis union yoga
union union with what with god with
source with infinity
self-realization it's by far
the most fascinating aspect to infinity
and it's like
also imagining all the different
creation designs that are happening and
all of their
unique ways that they're veiling
and that they're piercing the veil it's
so fascinating there's also the
introduction of polarity
so the choice being made between poles
and again so this is very much like
again like that
perennial spiritual symbol of the yin
and yang
where you have the poles but that you
have the
entire hole is transcendent the entire
whole is god
infinity source transcendent truth
love light ex but expressed here
in these poles which is the choice point
in this third density
and so you be you become aware that
you're a soul
exploring a journey
you're not just some finite biological
creature that is here to throw poop at
other people's faces
you're a soul on a journey and that
every single one of these decisions is
karmically paramount
and so that's the choice that's the free
will those are the pulls between
service to self and service to other
your creativity
are you going to serve yourself sts
service to self are you going to have
ego are you going to have greed
are you going to have negativity and
malevolence and resentment and
fear and anxiety and depression and also
butterfly affect that onto others or are
you going to have service to other
that choice comes up all the time
everywhere
are you in true authentic genuine
service to others in bringing others
value in bringing them more harmony more
bliss
more peace maximizing
our ecological sustainable growth and
prosperity and well-being and abundance
that's the essence of sto on a
moment-to-moment basis
and that's how you become more evolved
towards fourth density
and you can sort of see more and more
people leaving the egoic levels of
consciousness slowly
and being in service to other more and
more
in many ways the third density is like
extremely intense metaphysically
speaking
it's highly sought after like we said
earlier
and the reason why is because there's
just a tremendous amount
of these catalysts that are here
in the third density there's a lot of
contrast there's a lot of challenges
there's a lot of difficulties
and they're all compressed in a big
pressure cooker with a lot of different
mirrors
if you even go back a thousand years
maybe there were a hundred million
people or something on the planet
and that's a lot less mirrors that's a
lot less pressure cooker
right now we're extremely geopolitically
interwoven with one another we have the
planetary telecommunications that are
online the information technology age
the approaching artificial general
intelligence age
the virtual and augmented realities
acting as an awakening mechanism for us
there's a lot of contrast and choice
happening it feels pretty intense
there's choice with your family there's
choice with your friends there's choice
with co-workers there's choice with
people online with your mate selection
with entrepreneurship and north stars
and
that's a lot it's a completely different
than
being a dog in a house
but it's also a lot different than when
you get up to the fourth
and fifth densities where those things
don't actually have as much contrast
anymore
because you're acting as a channel of
the divine of god of source infinity
so you're no longer having these
difficult
decisions between the depression
and the flourishing or the positivity
and negativity
but that things are very naturally in a
state of infinite perfection
so the whole third density
acts as a big drill sergeant
who am i what is my source what do i
truly want
if you get kids that are
12 years old to inquire into the
question what
is i and they have to go through the
self-realization process
starting at 12. and by the time they're
18 or 22 that they
have had a strong guru and they've
underwent a process where they've
felt the infinity the god the source
we're gonna have a much more
robust flourishing anti-fragile
prosperous
civilization and that's where we're
heading
so it's not going to take three decades
up in the mountains at a monastery to
self-realize and become enlightened
and it's also not going to take
people like me five hardcore years of
trying to parse for signal and be
hardcore dedicated to truth to have it
yield
we're going to streamline this process
over time
so buckle in it's super exciting
and this is very much like a poker game
in many ways because what's happening
is is that the
the cards if you're playing a game of
texas hold'em
you can't actually see the others
cards and
then what you're doing is your
deciphering whether or not they are in
service to themselves or in service to
others
and so what happens is that over time as
you enter into the fourth density
that dissolves as in everyone's gonna
have their
poker hands be open and everyone's going
to be in service to others on an ongoing
enlightened basis
which is super exciting
and there will be challenges there too
with people that show
service to self that enter into the
fourth density but we'll touch on that
here in a moment
so in a sense suffering forces
consciousness to gain
freedom from the ego love that
so we're seeking piercing the veil to
become
more powerful more god-like more unity
become that diamond necklace that is
already around our neck
and recognize that we are an eternal
being having a temporary
physical experience
all right
density four love understanding
let's see if i can get the
scan converter to register that i
am that i have moved
should pop up here in a moment excellent
she needed a little reset there okay
so the fourth density and this is why
as the producer of a program that it's
important to also keep an
eye on your live feed on your program
feed
because there might be moments that
happen like that where some of the
software gets frozen for a moment you
have to reset it so that way
the entirety of the rest of the session
goes well so just a little bit of a
heads up for those that are content
creators
fourth density love and understanding
the veil starts to disappear
there's fearlessness of death
sensitivity to vibration
so from that mind-body spirit complex
we become a social memory complex
a group consciousness with no loss of
individuation it becomes more like a
hive mind
having full access to all of
civilization's experiences
like a walking library completely
exposed to each other
it's the disappearance of dishonesty
naked vulnerable
honest laying it all out
negative structures will come crumble
fall and disappear
in this the most sort of relatable way
to understand the evolution from third
to fourth density
is in many ways the word empathy it's
sort of
is one of the key words that we
experience in that process
so it's like
when you sit down with somebody and you
undergo a process of
opening up your heart to their story
and their journey and who they are and
you sit there in silence and
genuinely authentically give them eye
contact and listen and then
reply with really good questions that
show them that you're listening and
caring about what they're sharing
and that goes on for like an hour and
they they feel extremely
felt and registered and heard and
whatnot that those are sort of like some
of the first
sort of steps beyond the third density
egoic service to self towards service to
other
it's important to understand that
even though you're baby stepping into
that fourth density you're already gonna
be in a sense beginning to feel some of
the quote fifth density
needing to balance out that love with
wisdom
in the sense of you know if that person
that you sat with for an hour
calls you back the next week and says
hey would you mind
sitting down with me for an hour again
well at some point you may need to
create a little bit
of a graceful wise
distance in the sense of saying that you
know actually
i would love to but i need to be focused
on this other project that i'm working
on right now or i'm serving some other
people in some way
right so then that's knowing how to make
that balance with wisdom and that's a
core aspect to fifth density but it ends
up leaking into some of what you're
ending up doing
as you get even into the fourth density
so ultimately what ends up happening
is that you realize that and this is all
over our social fabric today if you look
at
like millennials and if you look at
generation z
and who's coming up here in generation
alpha
one of the most important things that
they care about
is the mission or the vision or the
purpose
of a company so if the
company's mission vision and purpose
is in service to others they're going to
do business with that company
if they even smell
even a bit of service to self they're
really sensitive today
it's super fascinating that they don't
do business with that company
and so you can almost see it happening
in the youthful perception and in the
youthful
consciousness that's evolving and
awakening
that they're not doing business with the
service to self companies
that they're doing business with the
service to others and so
even you as you're
an entrepreneur or an artist or
scientist or engineer spiritual leader
whatever you're doing in the world
that the more that you're in service to
other the more that you're very
clearly with your vision mission and
purpose align to only be
in service to other people authentically
lovingly genuinely
what's gonna happen is you're going to
grow
much more naturally harmonically that
way
and what's going to happen is you are
over time going to have more and more of
your own veil
disappear so
and once you sort of get closer and
closer to this fourth density and you
start
baking in that love and understanding
density what's gonna happen is
the whole notion of self-realization
that seeking
impulse it takes over it takes over
you it's so important for you to know
yourself as infinity as god
as source expressing itself
and that's what's going to rank you up
into the fifth and sixth density
the fearlessness of death is very very
common
once you sort of rank yourself up
because you realize that you are
infinite you are eternal
and that there's nothing to fear
but this doesn't mean going to the pole
of being stupid
where you're walking on the street
without even looking at cars
so that middle path that middle way that
goldilocks zone we've talked about that
in our direct path episodes
again so that very social memory complex
right
that's what raw was talking about with
that social memory complex
that had evolved on venus about 2.6
billion years ago
and that they he was six density so that
there was the entity with six density so
there was a social memory complex that
has formed
of this group consciousness is evolution
over multiple densities
and so raw had access to the libraries
and the wisdoms
of all of their experiences and was
trying to communicate that
to us through the channel of carla
rucker and so
we have to take these things very very
seriously because think about
sim similarly with us if you just
project out
as well as we evolve over the span of
long
periods of time what will happen is that
we will in a way
also serve as a social memory complex
to other evolving civilizations that are
trying to pierce their veil in the third
density
so in a sense we become mentors just
like raw in this case as a mentor to us
and remember there will still be service
to self
mechanics people can still choose to be
in the service to sell
frequencies as they get through the
densities but we'll get to that here
also in a moment
density five the fifth density light
and wisdom we talked about this a little
bit in four but if you're really
starting to feel like you're not being
over zealous
with your service to other if you feel
like you're beginning to balance in
wisdom
if you feel like you're serving people
without martyrdom without self-sacrifice
excuse me if you're learning
worthiness and unity if you feel like
you're spending more time alone
learning lessons of wisdom and
self-sufficiency if you're
only taking action when you're
respecting the free will of another self
that's when you really know that you're
starting to enter into some of these
fifth density
ideas and essences with your beingness
even this one was super beautiful for me
i had an example just this holiday
where i had
a little bit of egoic tendencies
from my mother and my uncle that were
infringing upon my free will
and i took a step and distanced myself
politely
saying that i can only
hang out this holiday if we're going to
not impede my free will and that
ended up not being their choice because
typically what happens is family and
friends
and other people when they see somebody
becoming self-realized enlightened to
that god source infinity
where they have a blissful and peaceful
essence
not always but sometimes what family and
friends will do is they'll do the bucket
of crabs
and they'll pull down the crab that's
escaping out of the bucket it's becoming
enlightened self-realized
and so to create that distance with your
family or your
friends again many of your friends that
you knew 10 years ago
again i'll give you another real example
from my life 10 years ago
i had a friend that i spent a decent
amount of time with
in college and that they
knew me decently well at that time 10
years ago
and today 10 years later i am a
completely
different
i i i
affiliate myself with infinity and with
god and source
on a moment-to-moment basis ten years
ago i was affiliating myself with the
name
alan and being a finite biological being
and all this other type of stuff so just
recognize that when somebody's trying to
say something about you like this person
is today trying to
pull me down that they don't know
me whatsoever they don't know my
perspectives my world views they don't
know
my relationship with source or my
relationship with infinity or god
and my metaphysics and the way that i'm
aiming to bring value to other people
being expressing that through me that
that is likely happening to so many
other people with their family and their
friends
and this density fifth density is all
about
balancing wisdom into the love
do not under any circumstances
go and begin sending them messages
on any of the social platforms
or trying to reconcile your loving
relationship with them
now i had a phone call with that person
about almost a year ago
about the way that they were beginning
to
express themselves around some of the
ways that i was becoming enlightened
and we healed a little bit there they
were acting as a strong mirror for me in
some ways
but today it's just become so blatantly
negative and bucket of crabs that it's
just distance
until there's a moment where the person
themselves seeks
and becomes more on the direct path to
self-realization themselves and then
maybe there's a harmonization downstream
and same thing's true with your family
as well
prioritize your relationship with source
god infinity as number one
and then secondary any human to human
relationship and that's what will
bring you the most flourishing
and you'll notice that the idea of wu
way or effortless action
like in the taoist tradition the daoda
ching
from lao tza what you'll notice is that
effortless action
naturally channels through you
because you've become an instrument of
the divine
and that's what right action is
and so it's become really clear to me
that i'm here to help people break out
of their ego suffering and quantum leap
to non-dual awareness
increase the vibration of consciousness
on earth
and joy being the light that's
translated in the physical body
and i've talked about this quite a bit
where
i am
the soul angle that comes to planets at
these pivotal
points in their trajectories in this
third density
and quickly parses for signal about
self-realization
and then aims to disseminate it to other
people to help them with their finding
and that's really beautiful that i found
that out about
myself at the age of 28 and in many ways
i was communicating with my higher self
and that's what we'll get to here in the
sixth density
and seeing if i had broken my previous
high score
because that's a pretty good solid
youthful time to have hit it
but i also am aiming to make the
pedagogical syntheses of
self-realization
in virtual reality and give that to
children that are
5 8 12 years old to help them pierce the
veil before they're a teenager
and that's the service to other and you
can support
us and that project in 2021 and beyond
you can find all of our links in the bio
below to support us on that front
okay sixth density
unity balance pure white light
100 non-physical
perfect balance of love and wisdom
achieved
i'm definitely working on this
the sds path concedes so service to self
path concedes to love and light
in the early sixth density so this is
sort of what we were talking about where
service the self can choose in this
third density
to continue entering into the fourth and
beyond
with the service to self mentality and
that's what keeps the light and the dark
in friction as they ascend
but when it gets to that sixth density
it needs to concede
to love and light
but there's many other creation designs
many other creation designs where
there's many other sort of
fluxes that are occurring
between the two poles in an ascension
process where there's different balances
and different vehicles of sentience to
experience those
creations and different styles of ways
to pierce the veil you really have to
use your imagination to
fully get infinity
to fully get the one infinite creator
expressing itself
and that's why all expressions of
infinity are valid
all choice
and expression of infinity is completely
valid
and that's transcends the right and
wrong and the disharmony and the lack
that we were talking about earlier
and so here all service to other has
been gained
as in you've really taken in as much of
the service to other
authentic expression that you've been
delivering
and you've taken that all in and now you
serve as the higher self
to all of your previous incarnations
in order to complete polarization into
the seventh density
you leave a replica of your
consciousness to the first to six
densities
so in this case it would be like this
when i explain my relationship with my
higher self
i have a very
it's a very spiritual tether in a sense
where there's a
there's a relationship with what appears
to be a
an ethereal entity that is
very clearly a representation of
a more whole
version of who i am
and so in this case it would be
my higher self that i'm in a
communication with
has already went through the process
that i've went through
so again you have to use your
imagination to imagine how
the quote atlas that exists
in the first density second density
third density fourth density fifth
density
all the way to that sixth density all of
those atlases
are currently being explored in
different creation designs
following different bifurcations
on their trees of possibility
so the atlas that never decided to
pursue
metaphysics and consciousness and
self-realization
exists in another creation design
where he has more service to self
dynamics
so if that's beginning to make sense
keep using your imagination
and keep recognizing that you have a
tether to a higher self
that you can meditate on
and create a portal of communication
that's more rich and more clear
and then leverage that in order for you
to
more clearly understand your expression
of infinity
and that's what i do with it
and this is in many ways where i am
feeling like
i'm kind of figuring out the the balance
in many ways right now between
love and wisdom that's kind of where i'm
at i'm figuring out the balance between
love and wisdom
i'm doing my best to become what you
could call mirror consciousness which is
in this
sixth density which is this pure white
light where you're just
acting as a channel of infinity of the
divine of god of source
in everything that you do is a hundred
percent of the peak morality
and so that's definitely where i'm
creeping up
and doing my best to to express myself
as and that should be a goal
of most of us is to slowly become more
and more of a pure clear channel of the
absolute highest morality
expression of infinity
but hitting that balance if you feel
like you're leaving a go at
consciousness again that first thing
is really hitting that love that service
to other that loving of
understanding slowly slowly slowly then
balancing that out with
wisdom and then recognizing more and
more that those two things become one
the love and wisdom become one as a
mirror state
of being so that's that general third to
sixth or so
okay and uh
density seven
okay gateway slash completion
so as above so below we
express all lessons in this creation
then give it back and merge with source
so it's just like a heartbeat
that starts again so we lose all
personal identity and memory even though
we've worked
all through all this creation design up
to the sixth density
we lose all the personal identity memory
and that's our passport
into the next creation so
our i am
becomes god in the next creation
and the next creation can be completely
different
the different creation designs have
different vehicles of sentience
and that's this beauty of this gateway
is almost like
every single one of this these lub-dubs
lub-dub lub-dub lub-dub or
or your your blood glucose levels or
your eye
accommodation or the
myriad of other
night and day
there's so many of these
and these juxtapositions are precisely
polarities are precisely what the nature
of our reality is
the nature of our reality is simply put
very simply analogized to our inhale and
exhale
because it's not only the breath that
gives us life force
itself from the photosynthesis of
phytoplankton and trees that we're
interdependent with in a style of unity
there
but it's also on a very metaphysical all
of the densities level
this is the beautiful process of the
inhalation
and the exhalation
the this evolutionary process that
reaches that
attractor that god head and that
goes through another inhalation and
exhalation
and that's the oro boros
and that's why we've learned all these
lessons we lose
all of them and that passports us into
the next creation because we merge
with source and we become god in the
next creation we
are already the i am god our i am god
that we already are becomes god in the
next creation
and we do the similar thing where we
create new vehicles of sentience in new
realities
we veil ourselves then we pierce that
veil and awaken
and that's the eternal hide and seek
exploring
all different types of experience and
phenomenology and fun and play
and we've been doing that we're going to
keep doing that it can never end
that's the point that's the nature of
this
it's beautiful it's gorgeous it's the
most beautiful
game in town and to fully wake up to
that
it's paramount all right
so that's the seven densities
again the links in the bio to the law of
one i highly highly recommend checking
that out
it's extremely thought provoking again
coming from
a six density social memory complex we
should take this very seriously
one infinite creator exploring
everything is love light no polarity no
right wrong no disharmony no lack
only identity ego individual versus one
infinite creator
densities as evolutionary leaps like
belts in martial arts that you master
and this third density being highly
sought after
again from that beingness awareness
is both eight and one
earth wind fire water timeless presence
no awareness of self to two
growth and movement plants animals
organic life the next level of exploring
creating separate self and
other and then three with the mind body
spirit complex the consciousness being
the ground of all existence
the center of the universe
the ground of all experience the veil of
forgetting
the most fascinating aspect to infinity
piercing that the process of that
so fascinating introduction of polarity
becoming a soul exploring a journey
deciding sts versus sto
really seeing your catalysts that are
actually in service
heading into the love and understanding
density becoming a social memory complex
with group consciousness hive mind the
disappearance of dishonesty
light and wisdom with fifth density so
balancing it out with wisdom without
martyrdom
learning worthiness and unity respecting
the free will of other selves
six density unity balance pure white
light perfect balance of love and wisdom
all expressions infinity are valid
serving as the higher self
and the gateway completion
expressing all the lessons merging with
source like a heartbeat starting again
passporting into the next creation the i
am becomes god
in that next creation
boom
just like that
i would love to hear what you feel
so write it out in the comments below
i'll see if i can get to it
and hit the ball back like the video
if it brought you value subscribe if you
haven't yet share the video with other
people that need to learn about the law
of one
again go and check out the law of one
it's so
important it's been really important to
me it's been really important to
one of the people that are very much
like my mentors bentino massaro
i'll also put the link to his channel in
the bio below as well
he's been an incredible spiritual
synthesis you can watch his mirror talks
podcast he does a great
job there as well the whole team does
and
recognize where you're at in these
densities
and do your best to continue
piercing the veil and becoming more in
service to others
and balancing that love out with wisdom
those are good next steps
do that message me if you have questions
simulation series gmail.com it's in the
bio below
pierce the veil awaken to
the true nature of your infinity
i love you very much thank you for
tuning in
and
let's wrap with the song
we are one infinite creator expressing
itself
hey one infinite creator expressing
itself
hey one infinite creator expressing
itself
ra one infinite creator expressing
itself
yeah one infinite creator expressing
itself
hey one infinite creator expressing
itself